Hello, Internet.
A lot of you sent me this image making the
rounds which concerns the Mayan prediction
that the world will end on December 21, 2012.
The claim is that the Mayan calendar short
counted the years because they forgot about
leap days so the world should have already
ended.
This is followed by Mind = Blown, which I'm
not sure how to take.
Do people think that the world forgot to have
its apocalypse or that were it not for leap
days that we'd already be living in the future?
Either way, it's spawned many an argument
that people ask me to explain, which I'm happy
to do, because my next big video was delayed
by pestilence, which struck me down into the
depths of unproductive misery for the last
few weeks.
So, if you haven't already, please watch the
related videos now as otherwise this won't
make a whole lot of sense and there are a
few corrections I'd like to make.
The first of these is that I shouldn't have
called the Mayans "Mayans".
Maya is the correct singular and plural noun
to use in the same way that sheep is both
singular and plural.
Mayan is the name of the language and the
adjective form of the word as in the Mayan
civilization.
Secondly, I showed a picture of the Aztec
calendar stone, rather than a Mayan calendar
in my 2012 video, which at the time I thought
was okay because the Aztec calendar is the
same as the Mayan, just with different names,
sort of like the Greek and Roman Gods.
And, frankly, the Aztec one is much cooler
looking.
But I was still wrong to show it because despite
naming it the Aztec calendar stone, archeologists
don't actually think it's a calendar.
And, speaking of stone, I used the term Stone
Age to describe the Maya which made many people
very angry.
For clarity, Stone Age does not mean stupid,
it's the technological classification of a
civilization limited to stone tools.
Advanced though their astronomy and mathematics
were, the Maya never discovered metallurgy
and thus couldn't move on to the Bronze Age
then the Iron Age then the Diamond Age.
Right.
Enough corrections.
It's explanation time for this image which
raised three questions: 1) Does the Mayan
calendar have leap days?
2) Did the Maya miscount the years, 3) Should
the world have already ended?
The answer to all of these is, no.
To briefly recap, leap years exist to stop
seasons from drifting out of sync with the
calendar, a problem that vexed Pope Gregory
because every year Easter and spring were
getting further apart.
To fix this, he introduced the modestly named
Gregorian calendar with its fancy leap year
rules to keep the seasons and thus the holidays
together.
But, while Pope Gregory cared about the seasons,
the ancient Maya did not.
Presumably because where they lived the weather
comes in only one season, too hot and too
humid.
So the Mayan calendar ignores seasons in favor
of accurately tracking the days since the
creation of the Mayan religion.
This renders leaps years an unnecessary complication.
Though the Mayan calendar is no stranger to
complication with its cycles within cycles
within cycles within cycles within cycles
that, if you're interested, Hank Green can
tell you much more about.
But back to the miscounting claims which comes
from our idea that leap days are extra days
which, of course, they really aren't.
The Gregorian calendar doesn't give people
extra days any more than daylight saving time
gives people extra sunlight.
If you transported Pope Gregory 1,000 years
back in time to meet the Mayan Lady Xoc and
then made them count the days until this year's
winter solstice, they'd agree on that number
because they're just counting sunrises.
It's not like Pope Gregory with his clever
modern calendar would notice 500+ days that
the Lady Xoc somehow missed, perhaps while
distracted by the pain from her thorns through
the tongue routine.
The only thing that they would disagree on
is what to call that day with Pope Gregory
insisting on December 21, 2012 and Lady Xoc
preferring the 13th Baktun.
So, this image is wrong because it's an apples
to oranges comparison.
The Mayan calendar doesn't have leap days
because it doesn't need them.
It counts days just fine and its long cycle
will finish on December 21, 2012, but the
world will still go on.